[Applause]
man you must be having this must be a
surreal experience I know that you you
must have known I've got a really good
movie but the reception this movie has
had the the the critical response has
been overwhelmingly fantastic and then
to have everybody in the country and in
the world saying we love this movie and
it's killing it how do you feel you hit
the nail on the head totally surreal
listen we loved the movie and you know
we cared about it and I loved I loved
every you know even I when I would watch
the movie very early on it was like wow
so many other people's great work I'm
enjoying watching here but then you work
on it for a very long time so you kind
of at some point you start to lose the
forest for the trees and and you're
thinking that's the best it's the best I
can do I don't know what to say right so
the world to come out and support us
this way and then like for me to be
sitting here with you is just like it's
crazy well this is your I think this is
your greatest achievement right here
[Applause]
highest-earning you're sitting where
Paulie sure you know it's so cool I mean
it's also it's not just that you've made
a really really excellent movie that I
really think is going to change some
young people's lives but you made it it
would a lot of people agree you've made
it at the right time at the perfect time
do you feel that way that that we we
needed right now
movie where a woman just completely
kicks ass and takes over the world I
totally feel that way it's amazing cuz
it feels like a long time coming and I
know that you know I wish that the movie
had happened a long time ago for many
other reasons but it feels like it hit
this perfect pocket and I've loved that
people have embraced it for that reason
and also even the fact that Wonder Woman
stands for love and truth and is is is
hitting home really hard that she's a
superhero for everyone but she stands
for great I'm an incredible badass I can
do all these things but it's actually
not what I'm here for I'm here to
inspire you that being a hero is
something bigger than that and believing
in love and believing in the betterment
of mankind is like amazing yeah
[Applause]
there's I have talked to my daughter's
13 she just saw the film and absolutely
adored it and I've talked to women in
their 70s that saw the movie and cried
at the end and I think that's a gap that
I mean I don't I cannot think of another
movie that has managed to get 13 year
old girls and 73 year old women and 55
year old men and creeps like me -
everybody's on this on board everybody's
on the same it's just an incredible a
credible thing
you